welcome to the coast of Argentina we're
about to witness the most primal drama
in the natural world
crafty predator versus vulnerable prey
only this drama has a big surprise
ending right now these adorable sea lion
pups are protected by a reef that looms
up during low tide when the tide rises
act one of our drama begins the bent fin
belongs to big Mel a 20 year old killer
whale that's been hunting this beach for
17 years the jagged fin belongs to his
30 year old brother Bernard as the sea
lion pups splash happily in the water
they're revealing their location to the
finely tuned
sonar receptors of the whales
like a dim-witted teenager in a bad
horror flick this oblivious sea lion pup
frolics in clear view of a hungry
predator and becomes his the next meal
big Mel takes his shot
close but no lunch this time Barnard
takes den a and grabs the second of the
three sea lion pups his body demands
each day that keep up his energy the
feeding frenzy is on big Mel grabs his
next pup
and bernard soon followers when a pup of
his own
but now the brothers employ their prey
as something more than food bernard and
big mouth will play no net volleyball
with they're still living victims are
they just cavorting with their prize
showing off scientists believe the
whales are actually training for the
more rigorous chases they'll have to
make later in the year in the open field
and now for that surprise ending we
promised their last catch is brought
back to shore
and set free is this an act of mercy or
play behavior we may never know